you know la i believe last week we tried
to talk to isaiah from
arkadelphia and we had a technical
problem let's try isaiah
we didn't get on last week did we isaiah
hi david can you can you understand me
now i can so there's no
loud background noise of some variety
i'm hearing no power tools i'm hearing
no deli slicers or weights being dropped
it's very clear today
you know i don't own a deli slicer and i
think it'd be cool if i did i think i'd
be moving up in the world to have that
um i was just um
curious i've noticed
that a lot on the left
because of um
a lot of
a lot of people on the left
don't like to acknowledge
that china and russia are really
threats
um and i'm not gonna like call out
specific names for such
but when looking at
i'm sure um you're familiar with what's
going on with belarus but for your
audience um
the nation of belarus which is basically
a puppet of russia
is essentially engaging in human um
human trafficking
and espionage to basically sabotage the
border of the european union
and i feel like
if you ever bring up that hey
these countries
may not necessarily align with u.s
foreign policy that we may disagree with
at times that does not mean they are
good countries they are
threatening to
the liberal democratic world order
yeah i feel like that's just something
that needs to be acknowledged more often
yeah i you know um you're you're very
much you're
it's a very astute point which is
there's a contingent of the left that i
basically
make every effort not to engage with i
just don't i don't find them interesting
these are
lefties who
in in the 1960s and 70s in argentina
when my parents were growing up
they were all over the place and it was
sort of like the
the west is bad people
and it doesn't matter if anyone if if
you if you're a part of the west and you
say anyone else is doing something
that's bad you're an imperialist you're
whatever
it's a really old script and when i see
these folks now
it just reminds me of the people that my
parents described kind of my parents
very much on the left in argentina in
the 60s and 70s but they found those
supposed leftists really as interfering
with social democratic goals not not
actually helping i try not to engage
with them because it's just so boring
it's so it's so passe
but you're absolutely right there are
people like for example if you look at
the comments of my recent clip where i
said hey you know what
um a lot of the china virus xenophobia
that we're seeing against asian
americans it's disgusting there's no
place for it but here's some actual
stuff that we could look at that china's
doing that we should be concerned about
it doesn't align with my values
and a lot of the comments are but david
the u.s does bad stuff too or you didn't
mention this one thing that the uh
we're not talking about that we're not
talking we're just i'm pointing we're
having a conversation where i'm pointing
out hey here's things that don't align
with my values i'm not saying go to war
i'm not saying anything else and you're
absolutely yeah and it's it's especially
disappointing to me because i'm fairly
young i was born after 9 11. okay and
what got me
engaged with politics is
every single day
growing up being reminded hey we're at
war in afghanistan and iraq
and should not be i know people who
serve who are just a few years older me
served in iraq also know people whose
parents served in iraq yeah in iraq and
afghanistan so that was never a present
thing so
when i voted for for biden and i live in
arkansas so my vote doesn't really
matter but i still voted for him
just him getting out of afghanistan even
with all the issues afterwards was
enough for me and then when i saw the
west
anytime anyone would say
okay but the taliban is still bad and
china moving in and their influence is
also bad
it's like two things can be true at once
the basis of being against a war in
afghanistan or something like that is
right
you don't want destabilizing
and
war words sure yeah there's a lot of
people where it's like it sounds like
they they say
okay either china is doing something
that's bad
or the u.s is bad and it's like hey hold
on a second the u.s has a history of
doing bad things and here's stuff some
stuff china's doing that
it's it's the black and white thinking
is uh is is disturbing and i'm glad
you're thinking and talking about this
stuff that's also curious um did you did
you vote in the uh recent argentine
elections i did not know i i moved to
the u.s when i was five so i've never
been registered to vote in argentina and
my um my documents aren't even current
so if i wanted to vote in argentina
first i would have to renew my documents
to be up to date uh update where i'm
living register as someone who's living
in another state and wants to vote it
you know i just have i've not i've not
done it i've never voted in argentina
yeah i saw the uh
perones
party suffered a setback but i to be
completely honest just don't know enough
about argentine politics to know if any
of the newer parties are actually
that much different in any way well you
just from the last 30 seconds you know
more than 99.9 percent of americans so
consider that a consider that a success
i i just know that south american
politics like to be pul like to be
populous and save power to the people
and then
it's one family controls the party and
pockets all the money yes yes that's
very often the way it goes no you're
you're
but hold on a second you're not
criticizing america when you say that
i mean i'm just a
oh no i was meaning specifically i know
i'm kidding around there are people the
same people you were talking about
earlier they would hear you say that and
they would go but the us has families
too i think they would say like well we
have the bushes no like the bush family
three i will say arkansas is getting
kind of a dynastic thing i don't know if
you kept up with this sarah huckabee
yeah yeah yeah is the only candidate now
she's going to be governor all the
others dropped out and endorsed her it's
crazy so it's crazy and her father was
i think for like 13 years here yeah mike
huckabee was a long time governor all
right my friend listen we've you've said
it all i'm gonna let you go okay
okay thanks all right very good guys
let's take a quick break i'm still
taking calls we're gonna take a quick
break and then go right back to the
phones in a moment stay with me